if you had to skin the Flesh of innocent
victims in order to stay beautiful what
would you do this lovely girl will risk
killing everyone she loves just to have
a shot at becoming a pretty girl I'm
going to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to beat the
flesh potion in Beauty water this girl
has no idea what Horrors she's about to
go through willingly in order to become
beautiful yaji here is your very below
average looking girl working in the
entertainment industry and she dreams of
looking like the Korean Superstars that
she works for one day at work she talks
with her co-workers about a secret
potion all the celebrities are using in
order to stay beautiful this guy says
that it's real but yeji thinks that this
beauty water is just another celebrity
rumor but she doesn't realize that she's
about to make a deal with the devil in
order to get it suddenly this pop star
redhead lady comes in for her makeup I
hate her she's rude as hell to all the
work staff and she tells yaegi to stop
being so ugly just then the manager
brings in and this pretty boy actor he
greets everyone and is very kind to
yeichi but then all of a sudden he
notices her beautiful eyes he's telling
this thieiji when suddenly redhead later
gets mad and tells her to leave throwing
various hair products at her later as
redhead lady and pretty boy are filming
this commercial this assistant tells
yaji that she can fill in for a role she
then goes back and is told to eat all of
this food while the commercial gets
filmed and that was her biggest mistake
later that night she discovers people
online making fun of her in that video
someone took a screenshot of her in the
commercial and now her ugly picture has
gone viral horrified she loses her [ __ ]
but suddenly she gets a text from a
mysterious number saying that she's won
a prize and that is about to be
delivered to her apartment minutes later
she gets a knock at her door and
receives the package she opens it up and
discovers bottles of beauty water along
with video instructions on how to use
the Prada it is shocked to her very bone
at what she sees however she's desperate
to be beautiful she try eyes on the
beauty water and then walks out to show
her family her new face shocked at the
results she finds the address of the
beauty water store and runs there
immediately at the store she meets this
mysterious blonde lady who says that
yeji would be the perfect spokes lady
for the beauty brand if she can pay them
two hundred thousand dollars so they can
help her transform her entire body into
becoming a pretty girl okay no no no no
no no no no this is so bad yeji here is
about to make a deal and sign her life
away literally by acting without giving
her actions any thought because when
something sounds too good to be true it
usually is and the fact that this
product relies on harvesting flesh and
placing it onto the body in combination
with beauty this makes this one product
something that could severely fudge up
yaegi's life so quick if she isn't
careful what they are asking of yeji is
to basically use her body and her face
to promote her products that she's using
and is invested in which sounds a little
like an MLM company MLM stands for
multi-level marketing and is a sales
strategy which the people working for a
company are financially incentivized to
recruit and sell products to additional
sales people who then join on board and
tried to sell and recruit more people to
the company getting a commission each
time they recruit someone however what
blonde lady is offering seems to differ
slightly and she's not asking yaichi to
hire more people only to provide
advertising for the beauty water product
using her new Beauty water looks to
market the product sort of like how
companies pay smaller Instagram models
to wear clothes so they can market for
the company rather than having the
company Market their product with cash
except here's the difference is that
yeiji will need to pay them two hundred
thousand dollars up front first from
what we know about this place and how it
looks it's likely that blonde lady here
is a big distributor of the beauty water
product and in fact used aggressive
almost dare I say illegal targeted
advertising to find a desperate aging
and offer her a free sample hooking her
for life on the product due to the fact
that she's super insecure about her
appearance because because if we
remember the package that she got sent
already knew her address in the first
place this means that blonde lady is
praying on yaegi's current circumstances
to make us sell and already knew that
yeiji would be willing to pay her a
visit and be willing to pay a price of
two hundred thousand dollars it's likely
that blonde lady will make most of that
in profit since the price for beauty
water has likely skyrocketed way up into
the stratosphere also it doesn't make
sense that this Shady company would not
want to advertise a product like this to
the general Korean public because the
amount of money that they could make
would be staggering especially when we
know for a fact thanks to things like
social media that a lot of people
nowadays are deeply insecure about their
looks and because of this I think the
reason this company is acting all shady
is because this product has not been FDA
approved or the Korean equivalent which
is the kfda if yagi is willing to get
out of her stupid little brain she
should cut her losses get on a diet and
go to the gym because investing in a
company that you know little to nothing
about is one quick way to ruin your life
desperate to be beautiful yaji bullies
her family into coughing up the 200
Grand and later she returns to blonde
lady's story in order to begin her full
body transformation but she doesn't
realize that she's about to change her
life for the worst she takes off her
clothes and lies down on this table and
is about to be put to sleep blonde lady
says that when she wakes up she'll be
dozens of times prettier than her old
self she goes to sleep and this Mad
Doctor begins cutting away and adding
newer flesh to her body hours later
yaji's mom returns to their apartment
when she sees yaegi's full
transformation and it's shocking yagi
has transformed into a full-on baddie
the mother is stunned as yeji thanks her
mother for everything but this is only
the beginning suddenly yaji demands to
borrow another five thousand dollars in
order to buy sexier clothes for her new
self the mother doesn't know what to say
but gives in and gives yeji her credit
card walking outside of her apartment
yeji discovers for the first time what
it's like to be pretty everyone looks at
her and her life has finally gotten
better she goes shopping and the last of
her old pathetic self disappears
everyone around her then begins taking
pictures of her wanting to hang out with
her and she begins to trend on social
media now she's an attractive stylish
woman and Yeti starts to get asked on
dozens and dozens of dates from fancy
doctors to CEOs and they all beg for her
attention and this one dude invites her
onto a boat party later tonight yeji now
realizes that she has not only the looks
of a hot girl but she has all the powers
of one too okay this is local because
now we are getting a first-hand
experience of what it's like to be in
the shoes of a full-on hot girl and make
no mistake these types of people really
do truly have a superpower which is
their pretty privilege which is the
association of Beauty with Talent
intelligence social success and health
pretty people are granted more
opportunities and get away with with
doing a lot more stuff on average in
this article by Q of's Studio they break
down the six social privileges that make
up the framework of what pretty
privilege really means first there's
Lucas which is discrimination based on
your looks Norm violations which is when
an attractive person does something
naughty and socially unacceptable they
then get a pass such as being mean to a
guy or girl next is the halo effect
which is when an attractive person is
also assumed to have all the other
attractive qualities such as being smart
the beauty premium which is when it is
assumed that a more attractive person
earns more and or gets more
opportunities to be paid more due to
their looks and finally there is quality
of life which is the belief that
attractive people are generally treated
much better have better mental health
and live longer on average these are
just a few of the examples of the powers
that we now have as a hot girl and JJ
here is utilizing her Newfound looks in
the greatest way possible almost this
beauty water isn't cheap and we can
assume that if this type of product is
circulated within celebrity circles then
this product is probably not a one-time
buy which means we need more cash yaji
is doing good when it comes to taking
out all of these dudes out on dates to
impress her but I would take it a step
further I would use one of these Mouse
suckers to be my sugar daddy and started
Landing me cold hard Korean cash and
this is exactly what iiji should do
later yeiji goes to the boat party she
was invited to and enjoys the High Life
surrounded by dozens of Beautiful People
yaji kicks back and relaxes just then
she notices her former enemy and boss
redhead lady standing across from her in
the VIP section yeji hides her face but
then realizes that no one would
recognize her old self anyways now
jealous yeji tries to head into the VIP
section but this CEO simp says that
she's not allowed in there and tells her
to settle for the life that he's given
her but she is unsettling for [ __ ]
storming off yaji is about to leave when
this guy catches up to her it's Mr
manager not recognizing yeji's new
identity he hands her his his business
card telling her that he's the man
responsible for turning this red-headed
Harpy of a lady into a big store and
that he could do the same for yaji too
she takes the card and leaves later that
night yagi feels her stomach and
realizes that she's put on some weight
horrified at becoming her old self again
she prepares her bathtub with one thing
she thinks will solve all her problems
Beauty water her mother begins getting
nervous and asks yaichi to exercise
instead of using this mysterious water
that they still don't know anything
about but yeji tells her to pipe down
She lays down in the tub and she waits
for the beauty water to work its magic
setting the alarm for 30 minutes as she
drifts off to sleep but that was her
biggest mistake without her realizing it
her phone had run out of battery causing
her to stay inside the beauty water for
longer than 30 minutes later she wakes
up and thinks that everything has gone
back to normal her life is now about to
get a whole lot worse suddenly she
stands up and sees the flesh Melt from
her body calling out her her parents
they try and help her but they are too
horrified at what they're seeing their
little baby girl is dying before their
very eyes freaking the hell out yeichi's
mother remembers what hiji told her
about this potion and both parents
decide to give yaegi some of their own
human flesh to try and save her waking
up later yaji is confused and walks to
the mirror only to see a horrible
monster staring right back at her she
screams for her life and her mother says
that they tried to give her body as much
flesh as they could without dying but
yeji gets angry and ungrateful and
demands that she needs more flesh in
order to go back to being beautiful
desperate and out of options she heads
back to the beauty water store she asks
the same blonde lady to help her out but
this time the lady says that she needs
to pay another 200 000 first before the
procedure can be done out of money and
options yeichi begs her with her life
and even Stoops so low as to kiss the
blonde lady's foot begging her to help
her out and finally yeiji convinces the
blonde lady to perform the operation
blonde lady has no idea the monster that
she's about to create later yaji wakes
up again on the operating table and
finds that her face has become beautiful
again she thanks blonde lady for
everything and says that her life is now
back to being perfect but suddenly she
realizes something her body is still
hideous and blonde lady then tells her
that she'll need to cough up the full
amount if she wants to fully transform
again yeiji then says that she'll go
find more flesh for blonde lady to use
on her but blonde lady laughs and tells
yaji that she's no killer she calls
yaegi a pig and tells her to get out but
hiji has become the one thing that she
never thought she'd be a full-on beauty
psycho junkie she suddenly attacks
blonde lady biting her flesh and mashing
her faces until she finally dies in
front of our eyes well yeah she's a
junkie now what did you expect there's a
reason that this beauty Water Doctor
operated in the Shady way that she did
and her mysterious practice and the lack
of red tape as now costed her her life
but what is Impractical and kind of
stupid is why yeji decided to kill the
only person that knew how to do this
beauty water procedure I mean if you're
going to kill her make sure you line
someone else up before you kill them
it's noted that before yeji noticed some
weight gain around her stomach earlier
this means that despite the beauty water
procedure her body began regressing
towards old ways within a couple of
weeks since she had the procedure done
from the moment she noticed her actual
weight gain she probably gained at least
four to eight pounds or one to two
kilograms if not more during this time
now it's not clear if her body is going
back to her old ways because of a lack
of a healthy lifestyle or simply
deterioration of the procedure but
regardless this means that all the
beauty water procedures likely last less
than a month before needing to re-up and
this means that yeji should have taken a
moment to think before she killed this
doctor she should have carefully
considered the fact that blonde lady was
the only one who knew how to do the
procedure and most importantly knew how
to kill someone in order to harvest
their flag aside from using blonde
ladies flesh here we have another month
Max before the beauty water treatment
starts to fade which means we'll need to
muster up the courage and kill someone
else before that happens yeji acting out
of emotion and not methodical
calculation has royally screwed up her
life so bad it's delicious and now has
kind of put her in a situation that she
doesn't need to be in also yeji's High
emotions means that she failed to
consider her greatest advantage that she
had in this new hideous body of hers and
that is the fact is completely different
to her beauty water Persona if bringing
a fresh corpse was the only thing that
blonde lady needed to help Yeti
transform back to her old self that and
two hundred thousand dollars then she
could have used her ugly identity as a
cover-up and go and murder a few people
being that beauty water would have
essentially erased this identity and
given her back her old beautiful self
she is basically the perfect assassin
the perfect murderer she could have gone
away with anything and no one would have
noticed that's when she hears on the
news the recent disappearances of many
20 year olds around found Soul she calls
her mom to tell her that blonde lady has
fixed her and that everything is all
right but yeji has no idea what Horrors
she's about to find herself in later as
the months go by yeji Rises to the top
of stardom and becomes a full-on Korean
celebrity she takes a break in between
filming when she runs into her manager
and asks him to drive her home in the
car she asks him where redhead lady is
gone since it seems like she's
disappeared from the face of the Earth
but Mr manager says that he doesn't know
where she's gone only that she costed
him dozens of interviews and film roles
that he got for her he showed a red
lady's social media page and tells her
that despite disappearing she still
posts pictures of herself regularly
online little do they know the truth
behind her disappearance is way more
terrifying than they could ever imagine
Mr manager then tells her that he
suspects that she's doing films overseas
thanks to a powerful connection that she
knew and tells yaegi that there is a CEO
behind the scenes that is interested in
making yaegi a world star but his
creepiness causes yaegi to escape from
his car later yaji stops by convenience
store near her apartment and feels
grateful that her life is now finally
back to normal just as she bumps into
pretty boy he asks if she's all right
but yagi is too embarrassed and quickly
leaves the store but pretty boy is too
much of a stud muffin so yaegi follows
him to a fitness club nearby she sees
him working out and decides to join the
club in hopes of catching him there a
couple of days later she heads to the
fitness club and that's when she sees
him excited and determined she goes up
and asks if they can talk and she
mentions that he was kind to her once
but doesn't get too specific he laughs
and says that he can't remember her at
all but notices her beautiful eyes again
he then asks yaji out on a date and
later yeiji asks if pretty boy happens
to know what happened to redhead lady
and he mentions that a powerful and
horrifying CEO thought she was acting
out of line and caused her to quit he
also says this is also the reason that
he left Show Business and tells yaji to
be careful in this industry they then
get all lovey-dovey and begin meeting up
again and again ever exchanging super
cute messages but suddenly one day at
work she sees her face suddenly start to
melt again and she begins to freak out
she runs back home and tries to take
another Beauty water bath before her
date with pretty boy and she asks her
parents for more of their flesh she
tells them that she's becoming ugly
again and they have no idea what the
heck she's talking about okay she's
crazy she's crazy she's really really
nuts this whole thing makes it official
yaji here is certifiably batshit crazy
and the fact that she has no gratitude
at all for everything her parents have
literally given up for her makes her a
despicable human being I do love it
though now it seems as though yagi right
now has a serious case of body
dysmorphic disorder which is a mental
health condition where a person spends a
lot of time worrying about their flaws
and their appearance if I was yaeji's
Daddy I'd put her in the corner for a
long time out and also a mental hospital
because she is so out of line yaiji
never once asked about the ingredients
that were in Beauty World which means
that it's very possible that the
ingredients inside this cosmetic product
could likely be interfering with her
thought patterns according to the
environmentalworkinggroup.com no
category of consumer products is
subjected to less government oversight
than cosmetics and other personal care
products in fact a California Assembly
bill has proposed that many certain
chemicals used in cosmetics should be
banned from use due to the fact that
some of these chemicals can present
long-term health risks when consumed in
high enough quantities and one of these
chemicals on this list is methylene
glycol a type of ingredient used in some
hair strengthening products and while
this chemical may be on the government's
watch list this chemical is produced via
the reaction of another type of chemical
known as ethylene glycol but this
chemical specifically is not on the
government's watch list and is another
chemical that is used in many skin care
products and is lethal in high enough
quantities some of the side effects of
this chemical are dizziness
unconsciousness and confusion exactly
what yeagi is experiencing said she is
clearly confused about her appearance
and has experienced all types of side
effect symptoms ever since she started
taking Beauty water this highly dead the
chemical and also apparently highly
addictive if I was yagi's Daddy I get a
gun and shoot her in the head and put
her out of her Miser and our misery
because I've literally given up muscle
mass for her but she's really starting
to piss me off coming to her senses and
realizing that she still looks beautiful
yaji rushes to go meet pretty boy she
makes up some excuse for being very late
and he then forgives her they go for a
romantic walk and get all cutesy classic
anime style when pretty boy takes out a
big girthy rock of a wedding ring and he
asks yaji to marry him on the spot yeji
is shocked but says yes the two
celebrate and pretty boy then says that
she should come over to his place to try
his special dessert that he plans to
make specifically for yeji having the
best time of her life yeji accepts to go
over to pretty boy's apartment and that
was her biggest mistake they head over
to his apartment but inside yeji notices
strange paintings on the wall along with
a family picture on the table she looks
at the photo and notices the pretty
family except for one girl who pretty
boy says was the smartest of the family
but was always ugly and always
misunderstood she also asks why pretty
boy isn't in the picture but he says
that the photo was taken before he was
born saying there was a pretty big age
gap between him and his older sisters he
then tells her that she'll meet the less
prettier sister soon but yeji has no
idea about what horrifying things that
he is about to show her prettyboy then
begins making the dessert as yeji
cuddles him but she suddenly hears
someone yell in the distance pretty boy
says it's nothing and tells her to wait
in the living room but yeji suspects
that pretty boy is starting to have some
real glasses guy energy about it on the
way to the living room the AJ notices an
Open Door into the bedroom and she goes
inside there and there she notices a box
and begins to open it up when she
discovers bottles of beauty water along
with many ideas of young pretty girls
the same girls that the news mentioned
had disappeared earlier along with the
idea of redhead lady and she realizes
that pretty boy is the killer okay this
confirms my theory that all pretty
people are major turd blossoms on the
inside and this also confirmed from my
theory that pretty boy from the
beginning had some real glasses guy
energy about him you know what I'm
talking about and this means that we're
absolutely screwed but in this case we
need to be extremely careful about our
next few steps it's likely no
coincidence that pretty boy is going to
kill us and him having all of those ID
means that he's killed before and is
extremely experienced at what he does
this makes our enemy methodical
calculative cunning and more batshit
crazy than us which is saying so but we
have to remember our hot girl training
and this means that we need to seduce
the [ __ ] out of pretty boy using our
feminine wiles if I was yaegi I would
collect my thoughts and go back to the
dining room sit down and tell pretty boy
that I have a huge case of IBS and that
I'm about to explode the back end of
myself but as I tell him this I would
say that I heard a suspicious sound
coming from the bathroom or the room
farthest away from us my excuse of IBS
will cause him to be thrown off and feel
as though he's under crunch time before
I [ __ ] my pants this will cause him to
not think too hard about our excuse and
do as he's told then once gone I would
grab the closest kitchen knife and perch
myself from behind the wall with my head
peeked out from the corner I would wait
until pretty boy returns from checking
out the sound and that's when I would
Chef the [ __ ] out of him and slice him
up the cops will not likely pin it on us
since we'd have an abundance of evidence
pinning all the sadistic crimes on
Pretty Boy and also yagi should have
known that being a hood girl would come
with some hot problems to deal with yeji
is horrified but calmly heads back to
the dining room and acts as if nothing
is wrong but pretty boy thinks she's
acting suspicious as hell he tries to
make her taste his sweet dessert but she
suddenly makes an excuse and heads to
the bathroom she tries to open the front
door but it's locked and pretty boy
shows up behind her and tells her that
the bathroom is to the left and yeji
quickly runs inside her heart pounds as
she locks the bathroom door behind her
but that's when she gets horrified to
see all the victims of pretty boy and
even sees pictures of her old self on
the wall he was watching her all along
yaiji is stunned and finds pretty boy
right behind her and try tries to stab
her with this needle but yeji bites his
hand and runs to the front door she
tries to open it but then is suddenly
knocks unconscious she later wakes up
naked and tied up and pretty boy reveals
that he was actually the ugly smart girl
in the family photo he realized growing
up that no matter how much talent
someone had all people needed or cared
about was Beauty and that's why he
changed into a guy with beauty one and
has since then been obsessed with
collecting Beauty he also revealed that
it was him in Disguise as redheaded lady
and was the one who had been posting her
pictures to her social media he then
drops his robe and reveals all the
beauty he has collected from all the
girls telling yaegi that he's been
obsessed with her eyes since they first
met and takes out this sharp knife
causing her to scream in pain later we
see Mr manager sending pretty boy more
pics of a new soon-to-be victim
revealing him to be the mysterious CEO
behind the scenes and he declares that
this girl's new lips are the prettiest
he's ever seen he then looks down fondly
at yeichi's eyes on his thigh and tells
her that soon she'll have the most
beautiful mouth in the world and that
she'll be with him forever and he gets
ready to repeat his kill cycle all over
again and if you don't want no pretty
boy to steal your sexiness then like
comment let us know what you liked and
of course then like it don't forget to
check out the how to be playlist down
below